and small business owners is what we
want to talk about now as you know they
are scrambling to get loans to keep
their businesses afloat during the
pandemic Congress is considering a plan
to give them another 250 billion dollars
but the details on that still really
need to be worked out
Goldman Sachs though is committing 550
million dollars to the relief efforts
the company's chairman and CEO that
would be David Solomon joins us for his
first areas network broadcast interview
good morning to you David Solomon very
good to see you hi Gail thank you thank
you for having me I'm delighted to be on
the show this morning
no we're glad to have you listen I know
Goldman Sachs has been committed to
small businesses for a very long time
but how did you all come up with the
five hundred and fifty million dollar
figure and how exactly do you want to
see that used so the cares Act is
allocating three hundred and fifty
billion dollars to small businesses as a
bank while we have a small consumer
business where we take composites
through Marcus online for consumers we
haven't had a business where we are a
banker to small businesses so we wanted
to use our platform to try to find a way
to get money into the hands of those
small businesses who really need it and
so we first started by committing 25
million dollars to help Community
Development financial institutions which
are in a way like banks that work under
the big banking system to get money into
very small businesses particularly in
underserved communities and places where
the large retail banks might not go and
the the purpose of that 25 million
dollar grant was to help them be better
prepared to get capital into small
businesses they serve we then said we
would commit two hundred and fifty
million dollars to do that lending
through those institutions and then we
recently just earlier this week doubled
that to five hundred million dollars so
that we can help get that money quickly
into these small businesses that need it
so badly Gail and David they are very
glad to hear that but listen I know
you've heard this too they're already
complaints from business owners that say
look I get on the phone I can't get
anybody on the phone I go online I can't
get online what are you doing what can
you do to make sure that the money that
you want people to get that they
actually get because it is a problem
yeah and so that's that's why we've
chosen to work with these Community
Development financial institutions we
feel like we're in a position where we
can work with them directly to help them
be better prepared to give them training
skills systems that will allow them to
get that money out directly the process
that you're talking about where people
are applying through other banks that
process is still getting up and running
we're hopeful that through this channel
we can get money out as quickly as
possible to these very needy businesses
and I think there will be gale I think
there'll be improvements I think the
other banks are working very hard to get
that system working so that money can't
get out to these small businesses but
this is really only a bit in place for a
few days and it's gonna take a lot of
focus and I believe it's getting that
focus and attention I hope so too
listen I know you've been in touch with
the White House a president has said
that he he hopes he believes that the
country will open sooner rather than
later do you see it that way too David
well I think it's it's it's very
important that first and foremost we all
take care of our people we take care of
each other and the virus is a very
serious threat we will beat it we will
make progress but I think the process of
getting people back to work is going to
be a slow and cautious one I think we
need to make progress on the virus
we definitely need improvement on
accessing to access to testing and we
have to build confidence over time and
my own view is this is something that
will gradually happen over time but it's
not something that's gonna be like
turning a light switch back on the way
we close down the economy to protect
people from the virus it's gonna take a
little bit longer for us to open up but
we are making progress and it goldman
sachs we're spending a lot of time
thinking about slowly cautiously how we
can start to bring more of our people
into the office in the coming months but
we're only going to do it if we feel
that there are a hundred percent safe
and secure and that they feel safe and
secure yeah listen I know you don't have
a crystal ball on your desk I realize
that but how long you know the job
numbers are coming out it
about an hour early later this morning
they are not expected to be good how
long do you think it'll take before we
are really the company that we put the
workers back on the job so your own
employees included yeah well what I you
know I feel very very good about the
fact that that were in an organization
where we have 98 percent of our people
working from home which is really
remarkable but they want to get back to
work we want to get them back to work I
think though that this is a process Gail
where no one has a crystal ball and I
think the best way to think about it is
to think about it as a gradual process
as we make progress in slowing the
spread of the disease as we have
improved testing in the coming months
and I believe based on the medical
experts that we're talking to that we
will see improved testing in the coming
months as we have better information
better data as we can take better
precautions including masks and making
sure people follow appropriate physical
distancing I do believe during the
summer we'll start to bring certain
parts of the economy back onto line and
we'll just have to work together and
make it a gradual process I know David
this has been a game changer for all of
us I never in a million years thought
I'd be talking to you from my family
room and you're sitting where you're
sitting right now and so so as knowing
that it's a game changer on the other
side what do you see the changes for
your company on the other side we all
have to learn from this and there will
all be changes for all of us and how we
do our business going forward well I I
agree with you it's a game changer I
never expected to be talking to you from
Goldman Sachs television studio where I
can't even see you Gail I expected when
we first got together to do this and you
were asking to do it I'd be sitting with
you you know having a face-to-face
conversation but we all adapt we're all
adapting well I know there's a lot of
discussion about what happens when we
get past this and how it changes
behavior in business my own view is that
something that we can talk about when we
get past this people crave human
interaction enough and as we you know as
we as we work through this I think
there'll be some changes but at the same
point when people feel safe and secure
they want to be with other people and I
know
we'll get to a place again where people
can feel safe and secure and they can
interact from a business perspective and
socially and I look forward to that as I
know you and all the viewers do too well
David listen I look forward to a face to
face because there's so much I want
people to know about you for instance
you know when you're not a financial
guru and wizard you are a your EDM DJ
this guy David Solomon is a DJ on the
side I like that there's a whole lot
more to your story thank you very much
for taking the time